لذلك لا توجد أسباب لهذا التسليم
لا يمكن أن يحدث وهذا أيضا
أظهر الفهم والعرض
هو أحد الأسباب التي تجعلني ممتنًا جدًا
يمكنني القيام بذلك اليوم بأم عيني
ما هو المهم بالنسبة لي أن أوضح
أن هذا التوربين يمكن استخدامه في أي وقت
هو وأنه يتم استخدامها
لا شيء بعد نقلهم
ضد روسيا باستثناء أن
يجب على العملاء الروس الإبلاغ
التي تريد هنا الحصول على التوربينات و
المعلومات اللازمة
سنكون سعداء للمساهمة في هذا
تحمل أن إمدادات الطاقة
توصيل الغاز إلى أوروبا دون عوائق
يمكن أن يحدث لا يوجد شيء
أسباب فنية ضده
يمكنك القيام بذلك هنا في الموقع
زيارة هناك حوار مع
gazprom لا يزال ويفسح المجال
كما كان من قبل ، توضيح الموضوع
وما هو مفقود أو
ولكن ليس هناك حوار
لا اتفاق
[موسيقى]
بواسطة